[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: This photo is
a little bit confusing.
It's hard to make out
exactly what's going on here.
The rope, the tiny
light, the night
sky the snail-shell
walls-- there's something
really abstract about it all.
And that's probably because
it's a place and an angle
that not a lot of
people have ever seen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The photographer who's helping
us experience this new angle
is this guy.
CHARLIE KESSNER: Hi, my
name is Charlie Kessner.
I'm an adventurer and
professional photographer
living in southern Utah.
This photo was taken
on a canyoneering trip
down Pine Creek Canyon
in Zion National Park
during the fall of 2014.
This frame captures my good
friend and climbing partner,
Ian Smith, at the
top of the final wrap
of the technical portion
of Pine Creek Canyon.
NARRATOR: So yes, there is a
person up there on that rope,
descending-- or repelling--
down into this canyon at night.
This is canyoneering, an obscure
and technical adventure sport
with roots at the very place
Charlie took the photo.
CHARLIE KESSNER: Pine Creek
is a very special canyon.
Like all canyons
in the desert, it
was sculpted by millions and
millions of years of waterflow
and flash flood erosion.
With this continual
waterflow, it
has left the most beautiful
scar in the Earth.
And actually, to the
best of my knowledge,
Pine Creek was one of the
first technical canyons
descended in Zion
back in the late '70s.
It's a very popular destination
for many individuals, climbers
and canyoneers alike.
Unfortunately, it's also a very
popular locale for accidents,
due to attracting many
inexperienced canyoneers.
NARRATOR: And the
dangers of canyoneering
go way beyond lowering yourself
down a rock face at night.
CHARLIE KESSNER: I would say
that the main misunderstanding
about canyoneering is that the
only difficult or dangerous
thing is repelling.
When going canyoneering,
more often than not,
one will encounter
everything from hiking,
wading, swimming, climbing--
as well as repelling.
NARRATOR: But
that's exactly what
attracted Charlie to the
sport in the first place.
For him, the reward far
outshines the risks.
It's all about
adventure, experience,
and feeding his wanderlust.
CHARLIE KESSNER:
Through canyoneering,
you get to explore one
of the most standout
landscapes I've seen on planet.
In this short life
that we have, I
believe that it's important
to get out and go exploring
in whatever capacity we can.
It is very important to
have a routine and a place--
whether it's a truck,
van, house, or otherwise--
to call home.
But it's the experience of
traveling away from that space
and opening yourself up
to learning new things
in new environments that changes
and teaches you and ultimately
enriches your life when
you do return to your home.
Whatever you're doing
and wherever you are,
I believe that you
can go exploring.
If you loved this episode and
you want even more "Seeker",
check out "Seeker
Stories" on Vessel,
where you can get all our
videos three days earlier
than anywhere else
on the internet.
Click the link in
the description
for your free 30-day trial.
And as always, don't
forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.